did you see any other and I'm putting
words in your mouth but frustrated
creatives when you were on Wall Street
or some of your other places of
employment at the tech startup people
that you could probably tell they were
just sort of phoning it in that they
really didn't want to be there but they
knew for whatever reason societal
pressure or the paycheck which is a very
good reason to stay someplace but I know
it has a price could you see that in
other people and also see it in yourself
I see frustrated creatives all the time
it's like her it's it's it seems to be
symptomatic of the situation is that I
mean I went through that long period of
trying to find how do I do this how do I
do this that doesn't seem to be a manual
maybe there is a manual but I read it
and I didn't listen to it I it's really
hard to take advice about this I find I
I don't know why that is but yeah I was
I would come across people all the time
I think I think a lot of people just
think that you can't be a creative and
make a living that you can't make money
from this I think they divided the world
people who are frustrated creatives I
mean I'm talking about myself really but
where I where I was then I kind of
divided the world into the creative
people that could make money from it and
those like myself who were probably very
talented but for some reason couldn't
make money from it no one understood no
one appreciated me and I I created that
wall and I think there's also
frustration because working on Wall
Street working in artificial
intelligence working in a tack startup
these are all defined career plans and
there were simple steps i could take
which is a person with a kind of who
likes to do things technically not
technically but logically and build in a
simple way it seemed that's what i
wanted to do and that wasn't available
for me in the creative part and I could
see that any defined element wasn't
going to do it it could put me into
advertising which is kind of creative it
could put me into a number of careers
which you kind of creative but
not not what I wanted
you